the center Sagittarius am i born of Xen
and the clouds embrace with sound in
hooves across the earth I fly a steed
the Salian with a human face sharp winds
the arrows are with which I chase the
leaves half dead already with a fright I
shred myself in gloom and to the race of
mortals bring nor comfort nor delight
when we think of creatures in Greek
mythology the centaurs undoubtedly come
to mind as one of the most recognizable
they were considered by many to be one
of the first human animal hybrids in
Greek mythology the vast majority of
centaurs are believed to be the children
of Centaurus the son of king Ixion and
they cloud fashioned by Zeus in the
image of his wife Hera the story begins
when king XE on through his
father-in-law into a fiery pit zeus did
not punish eggsy on
instead he absolved him of his crimes
even after having this divine favor
bestowed upon him exeunt showed no
gratitude and even attempted to seduce
his wife Hera warned her husband of
excellence true intentions and Zeus
fashioned a cloud in her likeness
when XE on made advances at what he
believed to be Hera he was caught
red-handed by Zeus and sent to the
underworld where he would remain for
eternity but not before the cloud became
pregnant with sin Taurus the majority of
centaurs are depicted as a primitive
tribe wild and lustful and at times
almost barbaric this was not helped by
the fact that they had a taste for wine
which re led to more crude and lustful
behavior
the caves and forests of Thessaly or
whether centaurs made their home and
they could be found using the
surrounding rocks and tree branches as
weapons while they hunted wild animals
there were tribes of centaurs scattered
all over ancient Greece
with one of the largest being found in
the Western Peloponnese there are
stories of a tribe of horned centaurs
native to the island of Cyprus children
of Gaia and Zeus these centres were
considered to be fertility deities we do
eventually see the appearance of female
centaurs but in much later literature
these centres were considered one of the
first true hybrid creatures being half
man and half horse
they even had some features such as long
pointed ears and a snub nose that could
mean they were pots a tear there is a
handful of predominant central figures
in Greek mythology
we often know them by name and they
appear very different to the other
centres the most famous centre was
Chiron unlike his barbaric kin Chiron
was known for his great wisdom teaching
ability and knowledge of Medicine his
role in Greek mythology was rather small
and he was only ever mentioned in a
handful of stories but we know that
unlike the other centaurs
Chiron was not born from Centaurus he
was the son of the Titan Cronus and the
nymph Valera he was often shown as being
of a higher class than the other
centaurs because of his superior
intellect it was this intellect that led
him to become tutor to some of the
greatest heroes in Greek mythology
include in the Argonaut Jason
Perseus Theseus and even Heracles it
would later be Heracles who would be
responsible for Chiron's death during
his fourth labor Heracles visited the
center Follis and as the two began to
eat supper Follis opened a bottle of
wine given to him by the god Dionysus
the smell of the wine attracted the
centaurs of the surrounding area and
they became hostile as they attempted to
steal the wine
with the use of arrows that had been
dipped in the poisonous blood of the
Hydra Heracles managed to kill most of
the attacking centaurs but in the
crossfire one of the arrows had
mistakenly hit Chiron the arrow did not
kill Chiron because he was immortal but
it left him in unbearable pain the pain
was so excruciating that Chiron
willingly decided to give up his
immortality and his half-brother Zeus
then placed him amongst the stars as the
constellation Sagittarius in some
versions of the story Chiron sacrificed
himself for the freedom of Prometheus
when he was asked to by Heracles much
like Chiron Follis was also considered
to be a very wise center but he would
also suffer a similar death that are
poison arrows of Heracles on that same
evening when foolís was examining
Heracles his arrows he accidentally
dropped one landing on his foot and
killing him instantly
as they did of Chiron the gods rewarded
Follis by placing him in the sky as the
constellation Centaurus another centur
that we know by name is nessus now this
is where you might see a pattern
emerging as necessary at the hand of
Heracles but this time it was no
accident Heracles and his new wife
Dayanara came across necess when he
offered to ferry them across a river
Nessa's took Dayanara across the river
first and it wasn't long before the
centaurs intention of abducting Heracles
his wife became apparent Heracles not
hesitated fired a poison arrow and hit
necess but before he died Nessus
convinced Dayanara to save some of his
poisoned blood to be used in a love
potion if her husband was to ever fall
out of love of her
the day did eventually come when the two
grew apart and wanted to win back the
affections of Heracles Dayanara covered
his cloak in the love potion
when Heracles put on the cloak he was
driven mad by the pain of the poison in
despair of what she had just done
Dayanara killed herself and eventually
Heracles would take his place on Mount
Olympus in this story necess comes
across much like the other sent or
unable to control his lust and desires
and even appear spiteful in death as he
sews doubts into dying Aras mind and
begins the series of events that would
lead to the death of Heracles there is a
very similar story that takes place at
the wedding of King Paris these centaurs
were king parithi as his half-brothers
and he invited them to his wedding there
were large amounts of wine served at the
wedding and the centaurs indulged a
little bit too much and became drunk
their mood began to change and
eventually they attempted to kidnap and
violate the bride
this caused the large battle between the
centaurs and the guests of the wedding a
battle that would result in the vast
amount of centaurs being wiped from
existence
the Centaurs seemed to pose an interest
in dilemma they may appear as half man
but they struggled to control their lust
and at times they are more beast than
man disregard in any morals they once
may have had we could attribute this
behavior to the fact that they were born
from the sinful lust of King XE on
attempting to seduce an already married
goddess as a result of his actions his
offspring may have been cursed to share
a similar fate and we do see them
showing very similar behavior the sins
of the father being a very common trope
in Greek mythology there are a few
exceptions of Chiron and flawless being
shown as civilized intelligent and very
capable of self control these centaurs
were fierce warriors with immense
strength and prowess but they also
represent the more primitive and
unpredictable side of human beings hey
what is up guys just a quick message
from me the channels recently hit 1000
subscribers and I just like to
personally thank everyone new and old
for the continued support you've given
towards the channel hopefully we can
continue to grow and explore new
mythology and universes as always I've
been your host mythology in fiction
explained
[Music]